this is david rawlings he is a master of
swordsmanship and weapon arts with over
25 years experience and is the founder
of the london longsword academy today
he's looking at some of the weapons and
fighting styles from from software's
newest epic elden ring you use a hammer
like this i'd suggest that you're
probably not going to have an intact
back to make it up the stairs i highly
recommend checking out the london long
sword academy all their links and
information will be in the description
but without further ado let's see what a
swordmaster makes of eldon ring
so the broadsword and here we have a
little bit of heresy if you notice the
grip in there it's quite long so this is
what i would call an arming sword and
sometimes this gets abroad called the
broadsword but sometimes a long sword or
a sword in two hands also gets called
broadsword so it's a little bit of a
throwaway term it doesn't really mean
very much
so for me if i'm fencing if i'm holding
a sword in one hand then explain utility
is one hand really it's going to be a
sword in one hand that's as simple as it
goes and that could be a rapier it could
be a douck it could be as i say an army
sword if the sword has enough room for
me to put two hands on it now i can use
this like a long sword and because of
having the sword in my two hands my body
structure has to change slightly to
adapt to it so effectively i would use
the techniques that i would use with
long sword and then really what we have
is a debate between the difference of
length of my blade and that of my
opponent so it's a little bit of a broad
subject for a badly named sword so
broadsword in the game a little bit of a
throwaway term you can use these things
in two hands and that's really what we
would call a long sword you can hold in
one hand it would be an arming sword or
depending on the blade type potentially
a rapier or potentially a side sword and
usually with those things we're really
discussing the hilt more than we are the
blade okay one thing that i will draw
attention to is there's um
if you if you like me and you play elden
ring you might have these points where
you kind of like you huddle behind your
shield and then you do an attack now i
want you to think kind of how illogical
this is if you're doing a block and then
you get to do an attack that means your
opponent can either carry on attacking
by just going well you're blocked now
i'm going to do another attack
or they have time to react again in some
other form so really you will very often
actually take the blow on the sword or
deflect with the sword rather than using
the shield so these sort of like hide
behind the shields
do something
not not the best use to be honest nice
little slips rearranging your space take
the blow and attack at the same time
take the blow quite often cut the leg
because people will naturally cover
their face which will expose the leg
this sort of thing is more the sort of
thing you want to see in sword and
shield combat
one thing that elder ring does get
really really historically accurate is
the art of sneaking up to someone while
wearing full plate or full chain and
just shanking them from behind because
you can't fault that genuinely
whenever i see the dark souls drawing of
the sword the ido style move and the
leaping forwards for some reason i think
that dead cells has got it so much
better than eldon ricky it's really
really cool it's just this nip across
the screen and you just take out
everything inside so one of the things i
really like about the uh the animation
of the japanese swords is that there's
this very very often this very good
commitment strike that there is an
intention to strike and cut and cleave
all the way through and this is
something that you should have with
european swords as well there is this
idea that you're really cutting your
opponent as if they're not there and
this forces them to go on the defensive
because then they have to deal with
something which is fully intentioned now
obviously in dealing that blow that you
intend to take all the way to the floor
if necessary and still remain balanced
which is one of the things i like about
the way they show the japanese
swordsmanship you do your big cleaving
cut but you're behind the sword you
settle in a comfortable position that
you can then move on from so if we were
doing this in lit to now tradition what
we would try and do is make sure that
our opponent has to focus their energy
on defending themselves which means that
they can't re-attack and then while
they're doing that at the same time we
mutate our attack into another attack or
we continue that same attack although
one thing does have to be pointed out
the use of edged weapons against
armor particularly full encasing armor
is is not good that's kind of what is
designed to stop so the idea that you go
riding past people
oh well look that metal that you're
wearing doesn't seem to have any
substantial qualities that's something
that could be addressed
[Music]
so the uh the flail of unreasonable ball
size this is this is an interesting
thing you really really would not want
to swing such enormous balls having such
pendulous balls would be an absolute
problem in real life they're really
going to be nothing more than hindrance
how can you actually
move and recover and recovery is a
really really important thing when
you're on foot and you're fighting
because if you miss so much of fencing
comes down to what happens if it goes
wrong so having such large and pendulous
balls is really really not a good idea
on a weapon now here we have a
historical something that you would use
and this is actually used very very very
similar to one of these swords that you
can probably see behind me these are
montantes so all of the things that you
do are going to be about controlling the
space between you and your opponent
cutting at them being able to recover
being able to thrust being able to move
around any potential defense that they
make and being able to recover again to
defend any potential attack or re-attack
that they make now obviously when you're
using a flail
there's a lot more
need to keep the momentum going so
you're really you're keeping going
you're keeping going and as soon as
anything goes wrong you need to then
find another way to get the whole thing
moving again because as soon as
obviously the inertia has gone out the
balls then you have a bit of an issue
so certainly the flail exists as a
historical weapon
but big pendulous balls on your flail
not good something usable that you can
recover with but the only other thing
i'd say about the flail is obviously if
you have something that has a half and
it has a chain on it and it has
something to swing again very very
similar to what i was saying before
about the doosan this can still be
trained it with in a one-handed manner
there's no reason you couldn't use it
it's whether it's the best tool for you
to use there are better tools so yes
certainly you could use it as an
improvised weapon certainly you could
flail with it it's going to be able to
get around shields it's going to be able
to do this kind of thing you could
certainly use it one hand if you could
certainly use it two-handed it's whether
it is the best tool for you to do so
properly
so the shotel um
i don't know very much about the show
tell and up until last week i had never
actually handled one what i would say is
i don't want to comment on the use of
this and i would suggest that you get
hold of damon stith and
ask him because he's an absolute expert
in african martial arts and i'd really
really like to see his take on this
what we're seeing which is consistent
with the uh the benefits of the weapon
is uh these descending strikes so from
what we know about shotel fighting that
it was very favorable from these high
high guard positions coming down
striking over and around the shield you
know even if you were to like parry it
with another sword or another weapon uh
the blade would would would uh
still manage to get around that weapon
so i'm glad to see those descending
blows which would have been very common
uh for that weapon one thing that that's
typically you know in conjunction with
the shotel is going to be the uh the
goshanda shield which helps to uh
eliminate some of the defensive issues
with the weapon stuff very strong
sweeping blows uh the shotel is
are typically double-edged but the
examples that i've seen are typically
sharp on both sides and so there is a
precedence for using the sword in both
configurations the grip is rounded so it
allows you to index the blade to be used
either as a
extremely curved sham sheer style sword
or like the sickle so
it's good to see that it looks like a
couple of times he's he rotates the
blade to use the convex edge of the
shotel and then rotates it back so
that's a really good um nod to both
sides being functional and the ability
to be able to switch between the two
all right so now he's fighting the guy
with his shield this is interesting the
awkwardness of this the weirdness of the
design is meant to get around shields
this is one of the one of the theories
it it would be nice to see
some of that action i mean it's probably
difficult to kind of portray that you
know on the game but
it would be a really cool um addition to
this character
to be able to have movements that would
allow him to get around the shield even
to like hook hook and pull shields down
um with that weapon
with
how did he step on with the shot
ah
rapiers the idea that arabia is entirely
to thrust is
ludicrous and ill-informed very often
people really
look at radios and what they're doing is
they're looking at the hill it must have
an ornate hill to some kind so therefore
it's a rapier
and they don't look at the capacity of
the blade so certain blades are made for
cutting certain blades are made for
thrusting and really you should be
looking at the capacity of each sword to
do both
so really quite often if we're dealing
with if you want to look at something as
being a rapier as being a rogue sword
again one of these arming swords i'll
show you well that's as robe as you can
get you hang around in your monkey robes
and we have a manual where people are
fighting with these things that's a cut
and thrust weapon how good a cup comes
down to the quality and the purpose of
the weapon you build so what i'm going
to do is i'm actually going to show you
a couple of small swords because these
are even more considered to be thrusting
weapons but the same choices are being
made so
here is a small sword and you could do
exactly the same thing with rapier as i
said which is really just designed for
thrusting but that's because somebody
has made the blade in that particular
style and i'm going to show you another
small sword this is not a spadrone it's
a small sword but it is absolutely sharp
on both sides and you could cleave with
this because it has weight and is
designed to cut and then it has a nice
slightly bold tip for the stabbing of
you
so what's happened is people have got a
budget
and they choose what to do with that
budget i want it primarily to thrust
because that's how i think my advantage
in fighting lies i wanted to be able to
cut and thrust because that's where my
advantage in fencing lies
so the idea that a rapid rapio is a
thrusting weapon is completely
completely freaking wrong it is a cut
and thrust weapon depending on the
quality of the blade you don't have an
edge on it you can't cut with it in the
same way as if you don't have a point
with it you can't thrust with it simple
as that however this rapier is not a
rapier it's kind of a sword in two hands
which goes back to my original point
that if it's in two hands it's kind of
like it's a long sword so it's being
used as a long sword would be if you
were primarily just working working on
hanging points which are just thrusty
thrusty thrusty thrust wind wind white
it's not really very rape here
the fittings are kind of fantasy long
sword but again i say fantasy with a
little bit of tongue and cheek because
historically we have made some
incredibly florid designs on our hilts
so fantasy is just our willingness to
buy gordy things unfortunately
so
no it's not a good representation of
either the argument of what a rapier is
nor necessarily of the form of rapier so
as far as move sets for the rapier is
concerned when it's held in one hand i
don't dislike it it's very very simple
you start with the point facing the
opponent and you bring the point to them
fairly directly and that will be either
done with your point hanging down or
your point hanging up or your point
hanging down from this side so it's
actually a pretty good set of movements
but i would say it's not necessarily
restricted to those of a rapier whatever
arabia
is oh the incredibly bad use of the of
the two-handed
the great sword or the spy handler or
the beaden handler or the smedoni so
obviously i have some very very large
swords and i can use them all like a
long sword because i practice with them
and there's information in the treaties
that kind of suggest that you should be
now
those things will be little hints like
it's a sword so therefore we should use
it like swords so i would however say
that swinging around one-handed is again
not your best use of something which has
got an awful lot of mass
use the two hands on the two-handed
swords and the truth of the matter is is
if you're holding in two hands unless
the thing is completely completely rid
of balance you can use in a very very
similar way you know there's this point
where you're just going like hold down
the y button for god's sake
just put it in two hands it's meant to
be held in two hands what the band's
there for now dual welding two freaking
big swords definitely i mean i'm i'm
completely against the holding one
two-handed sword in one hand but when
you got two two-handed swords in two
hands then i think they probably just
balance out two things i've really
enjoyed in elven ring are riding
riding riding riding more and those are
all parts abcde of 0.1 i'd like to point
out because riding is subsets of the joy
of riding and then part two is creeping
up on people using an increasingly
unlikely set of noisy things that i can
wear and wave around and stealth them
great
aha so the ridiculously big hammer for
all of those fans of strontium dog
so if you use a hammer like this i'd
suggest that you're probably not going
to have an intact back to make it up the
stairs so
you certainly have weapons which have
got a lot of mass where there's actually
genuinely advice of hit them with this
really big hammer on a stick
make sure you don't miss and the reason
being is because you're probably going
to get one go to do this and then what
you're going to do is a little bit too
heavy to use i would suggest that the
really really big hammer unless you have
balloons supporting it to counteract
some of the weight is a bad choice in
real life as far as i'm away you can get
turtle turtle shields so i'm obviously
this is not something you should be
doing you can get perfectly fine
synthetic shields that you don't need
and you can get metal
you also get things like rhino skin
shields and things like this and you get
leather shield so the idea of using
animal products to make something
defensive is is not outside the realms
of possibility at all
the things i really love about elden
ring is obviously exploring the world is
absolutely incredible i spend ages like
i say just riding and riding and riding
and i
don't fight nearly as much as
potentially i'm supposed to so i really
love that aspect i love how much
attention to detail there is on so many
of the weapons and i kind of wish that
some of them had a little bit more
access to historical replicas or
historical pieces rather i don't mind
there being fantasy weapons i really
enjoy that i also want to have the
overpower thing and frankly i spend most
of my time being a wizard because it's
easier
my name is david rollings and i run the
london longsword academy and despite the
name we actually deal with an awful lot
of different systems of fencing and
different types of weaponry all kinds of
things we're very very accessible we are
very lvgt friendly we have a excellent
excellent community and some very very
good new instructors coming through the
works i've been teaching this for
20 odd years so i really really know my
business very very well we have a very
very long established school in london
you can find us online as well and we
are absolutely bloody amazing
if you'd like to see more of david as
well as other martial and medieval style
episodes make sure to like the video and
let us know in the comments and i hope
you'll join me in thanking david the
london longsword academy and damon stiff
for collaborating with us on this video
you can check out some of their videos
as well as their other information in
the description below thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Applause]
you